comment allez-vous bon nouvelles
addictions il y en a tout le temps sur
cette chaîne youtube vous savez très
bien mais c'est ça qui m'anime dans la
vie ces dates a dicté à défendre des
choses saines dieu on a frôlé la
catastrophe
écoutez en cette période de confinement
dur il ya quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup
aidé un jeu vidéo auquel beaucoup de
gens jouent actuellement qui s'appelle
animal crossing alors cette vidéo n'est
pas une op c'est simplement une lettre
d'amour pour l'un mais de mes jeux
préférés de l'année après l'été de tous
les pays à l'été je dépanne vous ratez
pas non pour que tout le monde puisse
comprendre je veux juste revenir vite
fait sur ce que c'est qu'un animal
crossing new horizons le dernier en date
qui vient de sortir du coup parce que
sinon vous n'allez pas vous amuser je
vais tout vous expliquer à ma manière
et vous parlez de tom nook et de tous à
ceux qui jouent vous avez un sourire aux
lèvres actuellement ceux qui jouent pas
à pau - animal crossing c'est simple
c'est un jeu de type sandbox cette
phrase de la fois que j'ai dit c'était
pour terraria je crois est rare et est
un jeu de type sandbox animal crossing
d'angres au début du jeu tarifs sur une
île paradisiaque complètement déserte il
ya que toi et un mec qui s'appelle tom
nook et c'est là que commence ton
aventure quand arrive sur l'île comme
nous quitte a préparé une tente
il est gentil te donne un toit sous
lequel dormir c'est dans l'unique but de
thé ce croc et des clochettes c'est bon
c'est bon ou pas allez les clochettes
c'est la monnaie du jeu c'est pas des
petites fait comme dans peter pan quoi
bref comme nous tu te rends compte
rapidement que en gros il est là que
pour se [ __ ] de la gueule de ton
habitat donc au début tu attendes puis
ensuite de ta maison qu'il fait ou bien
comprendre que ton chez toi est trop
petit et que tu dois être vraiment
malheureux dans ton chez toi moi ça
m'allait très bien la tente il m'a fait
complexé s le fdp et du coup il dit
inquiète pas frais au moins j'ai de
l'argent je te prête des clochettes tu
me rembourse quand tu veux et comme ça
tu as grandi ton pauvre petit chez toi
de merde parce que t'es qu'une merde
ok c'est peut-être pas la vraie version
mais moi je les prix comme ça bref on
reparlera taux de moc après je vais pas
je suis en colère contre lui en voulez
vous c'est l'idole de beaucoup de gens
moi je le déteste
autre truc cool d'un animal crossing les
jours passent comme dans la vraie vie
c'est pas une temporalité différente
s'il temporalité qui est pareil à tel
point que les jours font la même durée
que ceux dans la vraie vie et que la
faune et la flore évoluent en fonction
des mois de l'année et des jours en
hiver par exemple sujet animal crossing
qui fait de lui plutôt et en été il fait
jour plus longtemps enfin bref tout
comme dans la vraie vie donc c'est assez
cool c'est vraiment une sorte de seconde
vie tom nook donc c'est le boss de l'île
même si fait croire que ces tournées
l'ex-étoile boss c'est clairement lui
qui gère tout c'est lui qui appelle son
pote couvre un musée c'est lui qui
prêtait clochette c'est lui qui prête
son atelier de bricolage d'ailleurs dès
qu'tu bricole et regarde pour être sûr
que tu l'unique pas sont établis
bricolage franchement c'est un tyran se
garer il est culotté
à un moment il te demande de construire
trois maisons pour accueillir plus de
gens sur l'île rien que ça le gars me
fait des prêts de centaines de milliers
de clochettes mais je dois quand même
construire trois maisons donc j'ai fermé
tout ce qu'il faut il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de trucs à fermer pour aller
construire je les ai construit et je me
suis dit [ __ ] tom nook c'est un bon
gars il a le coeur sur la main il va me
régal il va genre rembourser mon prêt à
ma place en me disant mec merci je te
mets bien t'inquiète cousin pas du tout
pas du tout en échange de ces deux jours
complets de farm tom nook m'offre une
petite clôture en noir et je m'en bats
les couilles de toiture en bois va chier
excusez moi ça reste un bon gars au fond
je pense juste que je suis jaloux du
charisme déjà qu'ils possèdent et
ensuite de ces milliards de clochettes
je rêve de la fortune de tom nos rêves
nous en but du jeu le but je sais pas
que de rembourser des prêts à tobrouk et
d'agrandir son chez soi c'est de faire
l'île la plus cool possible et aussi
d'avoir un perso extrêmement styles et
pour sa devinez quoi il faut un maximum
de clochettes
ben oui ça s'achète des vêtements joly
il ya donc plein de manières de se faire
des clochettes tu peut pêcher est tombé
sur des poissons plus ou moins rares et
qui du coup va le plus ou moins cher tu
peux aussi attraper des insectes pareil
certains sont rares comme les tarentules
les scorpions qui valent à ses chers et
d'autres beaucoup moins tu peux aussi
tombés sur des fossiles et les déterrer
est alors soit les vendre soit les
données à un musée qui se trouve sur ton
île pour compléter sa collection de
fossiles et tu peux aussi acheter des
tickets qui permettent de visiter une
autre île et de revenir avec un maximum
de ressources et donc de clochette en
gros tu vas sur une île tu détruis tout
ce qui existe c'est bon et tu reviens
sur la tienne était content parce que tu
as fait le plein de clochettes et tu
peux maintenant acheter ce merveilleux
objets qui se trouvent dans sa boutique
et qu'il faisait l'oeil depuis début la
journée ah je sais pas parler de la
boutique je vous ai dit le but c'est
d'aménager tourner il pour qu'elles
soient hyper stylé et aussi d'aménager
ton perso pour qu'ils soient hyper stylé
et pour ça il ya donc des tas d'objets
cosmétiques d'enjeux que ce soit des
vêtements des meubles des objets de
décoration bref des tas et des tas et
des tas d'objets c'est un cercle sans
fin c'est horrible et dans les trucs à
ses offres dont je vous parlais c'est le
fait que tu puisses customiser tout
c'est à dire que tu peux créer tes
propres vêtements d'ailleurs il ya des
gens qu'on reproduit des vêtements yoko
dans le jeu ds m'a fait trop plaisir de
voir ça merci beaucoup c'est adorable
jeanne meyer communauté qu'ils vous
disent tu peux aussi customiser ton sol
ton papier peint faire des tableaux bref
c'est assez poussées et ça a donné lieu
à des trucs cool comme par exemple un
joueur qui a customisé tout le sol etc a
créé en fait des trottoirs des passages
piétons etc et maintenant il a plus une
île il a une ville est bien entendu il y
a un mode multijoueur tu peux rendre
visite à un pote tu peux aller sur son
île donc voir ce qu'il a fait avec son
il pêchait avec lui choper des insectes
avec lui bref chilet avec lui sur une
île paradisiaque avec le bruit
la mer est une petite musique qui fait
du bien et c'est pour ça que l'on s'est
tant de confinement ce jeu me fait du
bien de malade et je suis pas le seul il
ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de gens
qui jouent
votre attention s'il vous plaît nous
arrivons bientôt à destination vous
voyez donc relever votre siège et salué
aux abonnés ok c'est parti ça y est
c'est le moment où je vais me faire
juger c'est le moment où je stresse
tellement que j'ai attendu 24 heures de
plus pour tourner ce petit moment par
contre moi j'ai prévenu le dessus donc
vraiment mettez vos lunettes de soleil
parce que ça tape très fort plus les
vidéos passent plus on constat des
dégâts psychologiques de ce confinement
chez squeeze alors on est en train de
s'approcher vous pouvez déjà voir à quel
point lille et son wall atterrissage là
ça me fait ça dès que j'entends ce bruit
et que je lance le jeu c'est incroyable
heureux tout d'abord laissez-moi vous
présenter mon personnage non pas de
godzilla le mec derrière me juge pas toi
la bienvenue sur mon île bienvenue chez
moi chers amis faites comme chez vous
non vous ne courrez pas dans les [ __ ]
de fleurs vous ne voulez pas mes fruits
et vous ne touchez à rien voici donc ma
petite maison à les modestes évidemment
je n'ai même pas encore les tâches que
tous les [ __ ] de riches ont déjà mon
nom je fais cette vidéo voici mon jardin
il est pas ou peu mais j'ai un nain de
jardin et je peux des chaussettes il
c'est lui mon unique ami petite tondeuse
car on prend soin sur cette île du gazon
il est vrai souvent mis de côté sur les
autres il d'ailleurs petit tuyau
d'arrosage pour prendre soin des plantes
c'est faux c'est de la décôte adam voici
ma plage privée avec évidemment hamac
barbecue serviette petit ballon pour
s'amuser entre amis
on n'arrête pas de jouer au ballon et le
nain de jardin là bas qu'est ce qu'on
s'éclate allez il est temps d'aller chez
moi ta dam bienvenue chez moi j'ai une
niche pour chien regarder elle est là
mais je n'ai pas le chien et qui va avec
alors c'est un chez soi un peu modeste 1
la déco est pas ouf je vous avoue j'ai
laissé deux cartons comme ça de
déménagement pour faire genre que je
viens d'emménager et du coup c'est pour
ça que c'est pas ouf alors que pas du
tout c'est juste que je suis une merde
en déco on a une petite plante on a une
petite barre de traction pour faire la
muscu si jamais on a besoin petite table
basse sur laquelle il ya ce truc qui est
stressant et relaxant à la fois on a le
petit bambou au mur la petite lampe far
from vraiment c'est basique mais on a
une chambre d'amis ce panneau annonce
d'ailleurs l'indignité que représente
cette chambre d'amis êtes vous prêts
n'hésitez pas voilà donc n'hésitez pas
il ya tout ce qu'il faut
micro-ondes conserve de nourriture
urinoirs balai pour nettoyer temps en
temps il ya tout ce qu'il faut c'est la
chambre dont vous rêvez je le sais et
récemment j'ai réussi à rembourser mon
8000e prêt auprès de toluca et j'ai donc
une nouvelle pièce qui est un début
modeste de buanderie salle de bain voilà
le meilleur élément étant cette
merveilleuse bmc qui tourne là où ça
manque d'ailleurs d'une poubelle à
roulettes je trouve bon oublier cette
pièce elle et elle est en train boxer et
voilà c'était mon chez moi
n'hésitez pas à visiter mon île quand je
joue et que je partage mon monde au dos
code je le ferai jamais vous allez
courir dans les fleurs je vous fais pas
confiance à oui j'ai aussi une petite
rue ici j'ai fait une ruche mais j'ai
jamais vu une seule abeilles je me sens
seul sur cette île voilà maintenant vous
êtes un peu plus familier avec le jeu on
va pouvoir faire de la réaction je
repose donc qu'on ait checké en somme
tout ce qui se fait de mieux sur ce jeu
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on tournait
beaucoup de choses qui ont été
découvertes c'est ça qui est cool avec
les jeux comme animal crossing avec les
sandbox et avec minecraft par exemple à
l'époque à la grande époque de minecraft
c'est que comme c'est des jeux ouverts
est vraiment des cours de récréation
j'appelle ça de la communauté fait trop
de trucs marrants les gens sont
hilarants les situations sont hilarantes
et on va checker tous ensemble
aujourd'hui
alors il voulait montrer sa super prise
contexte si jamais dans le jeu quant à
pêcher un poisson tu peux l'exhiber
c'est à dire en gros tu peux le prendre
dans tes mains pour montrer ce que tu
viens de pêcher mais tu peux aussi à une
autre option c'est le relâcher auquel
cas tu leur mets dans l'eau et si chao
auquel est en train de pêcher il ya son
pack qui arrive
carbo style son pâté là ils s'excitent
il veut lui montrer quelque chose c'est
sûr y voir la chaîne poisson au nom il
avait pêché un [ __ ] de requins
marteaux sabots assez cher ça vaut pas
mal de clochettes
ok elle tombe sur une ruche d'abeilles
n'est pas contre ce coup d arrêt d avec
l'état en tulle
o o
[Musique]
je reviens sur ces quelques images pour
ceux qui ne jouent pas normal qu'on sait
qu'ils n'ont pas compris alice était
pourchassé par des abeilles ça arrive
dans les maquereaux 50 ce qu un arbre
elle tombe sur une tarentule qu'est
l'inseec le plus veinard du jeu s'il te
touche tut évanouie chao avec son fils
et elle attrape les abeilles mais le
filet casse parce que tous les outils
dans les malles crossing ils ont une
durée de vie au bout d'un moment il se
pète du coup elle ne peut plus attraper
l'araignée et l'araignée la termine
comme il se doit
j'adore les enchaînements de malchance
[ __ ] ça me flingue au caire hamas de
petites branches là ce que voyez c'est
pas un joueur à côté c'est un habitant
de son village mais ceux capturés
franchement pas l'écart par ouais c'est
pour ça que moi je voulais être seul sur
mon île les habitants qui sont ingrats
mec franchement tu customiser lille tu
bosses jour et nuit tuent leur construit
leur maison et ils s'assoient sur
l'insecte que tu veux capturés ils ont
aucune forme de respect notre fiancée
moi avons dû annuler notre mariage à
cause du coronavirus du coup à la place
de meilleurs amis nous ont fait un
mariage surprise dans animal crossing
oignons je te passer pour un fou pour
ceux qui jouent pas vous rendez pas
compte comme quand tu te rassemble sur
une île avec des potes et campus talent
vocal c'est incroyable c'est vraiment
trop drôle
et en ces temps de confinement c'est
vraiment une seconde vie que tu vis un
peu au premier degré c'est marrant quand
j'ai fait une petite blague je vais
mettre ça partout sur l'île de ma petite
amie
non c'est génial tu peut customiser le
sol et le gars a fait l'icône que y'a
par terre quand il ya un fossile en fait
cela n'y a pas de faux cils c'est juste
lui qui a mis une image quoi qu'elle bat
mais voyez à trop de possibilités là
dedans j'ai visité l'île de ma petite
amie et elle sait comme vous renvoie
cuir avec un tapis rouge
je précise quand arrive sur l'île d'un
ami il ya une petite cinématique où tu
vois du dessus sont ils
welcome beach merde comme film sa bosse
et du bois je vous disais oh attendez
c'est un truc qui va me réconcilie avec
tom nook quant à donner 90% ton argent à
des associations que tu as eu une
enfance dépressive que t'a offert aux
gens des maisons que tu as acheté aux
gens leurs fournitures inutile que tu as
vendu des trucs très utile en retour que
tu prends leurs nouvelles tous les jours
que tu attends sans broncher que les
gens tu rembourses mais que les gens
continuent de penser que tu es un petit
tanuki égoïste et un énorme capitaliste
je savais pas tolno pour tout ça moi
tout ce que j'ai vu c'est que tu parlais
de ma maison tout en disant qu'elle
était trop petit homme tout le tort je
deviens fou un sursis un petit rappel
pour tous ceux qui jouent à leur rythme
c'est pas grave si vous ne progressait
pas aussi vite que les autres joueurs
c'est vrai tous mes amis ont déjà
remboursé leur cinquième près moi je
suis qu'au deuxième j'ai environ 90
thème que les autres j'ai un petit
complexe qui s'écrit d'infériorité que
ce cher écoutez moi bien je vous jure
que ce jeu ça devient concours de [ __ ]
et je veux rien entendre
vous le savez tous les joueurs on est
tous navires sur mon île tu veux juste
montrer à quel point sa maison est belle
et à quel point tourner il est avancé
par rapport à la mienne à moi j'ai mon
break mes amis dans pas longtemps le
moyen le plus rapide de rembourser
toutes ses dettes envers tom nook j'ai
ton fils annuler toutes les dettes si tu
veux le retrouver en un seul morceau
c'est le cri j'ai dit à deux teams ya
ceux qui aiment tom nook et 2 et qui
sont reconnaissants envers lui et à ceux
comme moi qui peuvent pas le blairer
même fait complexé c'est tout je peux
pas j'arrive pas à l'aimer et on débat
sur un [ __ ] de tanuki virtuel c'est
bon j'ai fait de mon île une ville
japonaise mais vas-y
[Musique]
excusez moi c'est le visage d'un homme
en train de complexer poids mais le
level il ya des gens ils ont des
cuisines complète quoi trop bien trop
tout va bien lucas chacun joue à ce
rythme on met du coup il est tout ça
trop bien il a il est un bain japonais
quoi moi j'ai un bouton d'essence je
comprenais la différence alors peut-être
que je peux me baigner dedans mais c'est
j'ai pas envie quoi j'ai pris un risque
en achetant 2200 radi dimanche dernier
je suis allé sur l'une d'un pote et il
les racheter à 560 l'unité je suis
devenu millionnaire et ça ne fait même
pas une semaine que le jeu est sorti
j'en ai marre moi je n'ai même pas jeter
de radier encore chez même pas c'est
quoi c'est ouf comme moi dans la vraie
vie je m'en fous de qui a les objets
piste et je sais pas quoi mais doit
animal crossing ça me rend fou
je suis plus sensible aux écarts de
style et de richesse dans le jeu vidéo
que dans la vraie vie c'est c'est
horrible aulas faut peut-être que de
montage ça c'est charles la carrière
ouah
à regarder la cuisine trop belle de
personnes quoi à temps mais elle a
carrément fait un petit café et tout
alors je vais aller faut que je joue ma
confortables chambres d'isolation trop
bien là mais j'ai pas un dixième de ces
objets il faut que je joue si tu quand
paris je comprends que je passe autant
dessus maintenant il faut que je joue il
n'y a rien de mal dans le fait d'avancer
à son propre rythme tourner il est belle
peu importe comme elle est c'est faux je
vais jouer c'est trop c'est trop
bon eh bien écoutez c'est la fin de
cette vidéo je fais ça vous aura plu
même si vous n'avez pas joué au jeu vous
connaissiez pas vous avez cette chaîne
j'adore parler de choses que je fais en
ce moment quoi et lancement je joue
beaucoup à ce jeu c'est chose faite
on se retrouve bientôt sur mon île je
vous jure je vais tout donner pour
qu'ils soient hostiles
ma détermination est sans précédent je
vais jouer trois fois plus qu'avant je
veux dire des instances de prochaine
vidéo merci d'avoir regardé désolé pour
ceux qui connaissaient pas j'espère que
vous aurez pris du plaisir et puis à
bientôt six ou
[Musique]